welcome back we're continuing our
coverage of hispanic heritage month this
morning for about 15 years our maria
viral has been on the front lines of the
immigration story she's been covering
every angle of this issue on both sides
of the southern border this morning she
reflects on the values that have guided
her reporting
[Music]
in april of 2018 in tijuana mexico we
were reporting on this large caravan of
migrants asylum seekers it was unlike
anything i had ever covered before but i
figured we'd be done with the story in a
few days watch the caravan
watch how sad and terrible it is
i soon found myself in the middle of
what was quickly becoming the nation's
most polarizing issue and
i resisted
honestly i was secretly hoping i'd get
assigned to something else i didn't want
to be the correspondent covering this
issue just because i was latina or i
spoke spanish
i kept thinking to myself
i'm better than this
and then family separation hit
a newly open tent city along the texas
border is at the heart of the national
immigration debate
despite several requests we are not
being allowed inside the tornillo
facility
family separation was the trump
administration's way of aggressively
dealing with these immigration issues
federal agents were instructed to pull
families apart the message was clear to
these asylum seekers
don't come here or this will happen to
you
this time i didn't resist covering the
story
covering these stories as a new mom was
very difficult for me i had a
two-year-old boy at home and i'd be gone
for weeks at a time
but i kept telling myself
this is where i need to be
to this day
i still think about three-year-old
sophia and her grandmother angelica they
followed the rules
and that little girl was
still
pulled away from the only family that
she knew and placed with complete
strangers
three months later they were reunited
the damage was already done two behind
me right now three in the brush as a
journalist i tried to stay objective as
possible but i also made an effort to
add perspective to these stories that no
one else could for me this wasn't about
politics it was about adding humanity to
the stories we were telling about people
that were actually stuck in the middle
of the politics
by far the hardest part for me has
always been talking to the children
as a journalist i want to know how they
got to the border who brought them
but as a mother
and really as a human being i just want
to know that as they're walking away
into the dark that someone is watching
over them
but after years of covering these
immigration stories i realize that the
people who care about these stories
aren't always latinos a perfect example
is the producer who often works with me
on these stories his family is from
india he lives in new jersey and yet he
is with me on these stories at a
moment's notice when i ask
he like me takes great care with the
reporting because this is a migration
issue a people issue and not just a
hispanic issue
[Music]
latinos are a proud hard-working
passionate group of people
we aren't a monolithic group and our
story is way bigger than the border and
there's no better example of that than
the roster of latinos i get to call
colleagues migente
cubans puerto ricans
people from latin america
mexican-americans
and while we may all be different we all
have this one common goal
and that's to represent our culture
with respect dignity
empathy
[Music]
man i mean marey is so first of all her
coverage is terrific along the border
and and secondly she's she's right when
she says this is a human story it's a
story of migration we're all descended
in some way from migrants and the only
difference between the people on the
border today and many families that came
here in the 1800s or the 1700s the only
difference is time mm-hmm yeah working
in this space there's stories that fall
on our lap and we tell them because of
our jobs right and then there's stories
that our heart tells us that we have to
cover and for maria this is one of those
yeah just watching that i mean you
couldn't help but
i mean marae is such a real
person love her i think that was a great
piece and you just understand it's
difficult to cover that type of stuff
but as she said it's humanity and all of
us bringing our different unique
perspectives to the stories we cover and
it's tough not to get lost in that
humanity yeah when you're seeing these
families in so much pain going through
what they've been through definitely a
good job well done great job maria